دعوا هذه الابويه في التعامل معنا هكذا
قال الرئيس الكونغو الديمقراطيه فيليكس
تشيسكيدي لضيفه الرئيس الفرنسي مانويل
ماكرون في الخامس من مارس هذا العام
والابويه هي مقتل فرنسا في تعاطيها مع
القاره الافريقيه ومع مستعمراتها السابقه
على نحو اخص في نبره الرئيس الكونغولي
المتشكيه من فرنسا ما يشير الى ما باتا
يعرف بالتراجع النفوذ الفرنسي في القاره
الافريقيه
فثلاث من الدول الافريقيه التي كانت
مستعمرات سابقه لفرنسا تكسر قيدها عبر
انقلابات عسكريه استقلت مزاجا شعبيا بات
كارها للوجود الفرنسي الذي لم يغير نظرته
الى المستعمرات السابقه فهي عنده مستودع
للموارد لا ينضب
الانقلاب الاخير في النيجر ورغم انه شكل
مصادره لتجربه ديمقراطيه لكنه عبر في
الوقت نفسه عن تحول لم يعد خافيا على
فرنسا وعلى الغرب بشكل عام واول هذه
المعطيات ان الارث الاستعماريه ليس بضمانه
لاستبقاء افريقيا لا سيما افريقيا التي
استعمرتها فرنسا
والاستعمار الفرنسي في القاره الافريقيه
قصه معقده ففرنسا ثاني دوله اوروبيه بعد
الامبراطوريه البريطانيه تبسط سلطانها
ولسانها على الشعوب الافريقيه فارضه
نفوذها على عشرين دوله بينما تصدرت
بريطانيا القوه الاستعماريه باثنتين
وعشرين دوله في القاره الافريقيه وحدها
كانت فرنسا اكثر الدول تشبثا بمستعمراتها
واكثرها بطئا في الخروج منها واكثرها حيله
في ربط اقدار هذه المستعمرات بفرنسا فصنعت
فضاء فرانكفورنيا ونخبه متعلقه بها وصنعت
لمستعمراتها فرنكا كعملتها واجبرت الدول
الافريقيه على ايداع نصف ارصدتها في البنك
المركزي الفرنسي وجعلت من موارد هذه الدول
شريانا مقدما لاقتصادها دون كبير عنايه
بتطوير اقتصاديات هذه الدول في وسط وغرب
افريقيا ثلاثه قلابات تقع تباعا في قلب
مناطق النفوذ الفرنسي في القاره اخرها
انقلاب النيجر بعد انقلابين في مالي في
الخامس والعشرين من مايو 2021
وانقلاب في بوركينا فاسو في الاسبوع
الاخير من شهر يناير العام الماضي
وانفرط العقد الفرنسي بانقلاب النيجر
ويبدو ان مقوله الرئيس الفرنسي السابق
نيكولا ساركوزي ستتخذ شكلا تهكميا ليس على
الافارقه هذه المره بل على فرنسا نفسها
قال سركوزي عام 2007 ان الانسان الافريقيه
لم يدخل التاريخ حتى الان كما ينبغي ويبدو
ان الدول الافريقيه الثلاث خرجت بالفعل من
التاريخ في وصفته الفرنسيه لتدخل تاريخا
اخر تاريخ تتنافس على صناعته دول غير
اوروبيه هي الصين وروسيا هنا مدينه سام
بطرسبيرك حيث الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين حفي بضيوف الافارقه من نحو 44 بلدا
افريقيا يسجلون حضورهم في القمه الروسيه
الافريقيه
ويتطلعون الى تعاون بلا حدود في المجالات
كافه من الاسلحه والامن الى التكنولوجيا
الى الزراعه الى التبادلات التجاريه ووراء
كل ذلك احلام مشتركه حول عالم تتعدد
اقطابه لكن روسيا لا تبلغ مبلغ الصين التي
استطاعت في اقل من ثلاثه عقود ان تكون
الشركه التجاريه الاكبر للقاره الافريقيه
حيث تجاوز حجم التجاره مع افريقيا 200
مليون دولار وتوجد اكثر من عشره الاف شركه
صينيه تعمل في القاره منذ العام 2005 بحجم
استثمارات تجاوزت ريليوني دولار امريكا
بايدن المنشغله بمقلقات نفوذها في البر
والبحر تسيطر على اجندتها مفاعيل الصراعات
ذات الصمت الاوروبي مع الصين تحديدا فضلا
عن روسيا وطامعين اخرين في الصعود الى
القمه امريكا ايضا تطمح الى تحقق وجود في
افريقيا لكنها لا تنفعل بهذا الوجود في
ذاته بل من خلال خشيتها من التوكل الصيني
والروسي الاقل منه في حمى هذا الصراع
المتصل اصلا بالقوه والنفوذ يستدعي انقلاب
النيجر مداخل لا تكشف عن وجه المصالح بل
ربما تخفت في خطاب سياسي يعني من قيمه
الديمقراطيه في القاره يقول وزير الخريات
الامريكي
ان بلاده تعمل على اعاده الحكم الديمقراطي
وان علاقاتها الاقتصاديه مع النيجر تتوقف
على هذا الامر وكذلك يفعل الاتحاد
الاوروبي فرنسا تعلق مساعداتها للنيجر
وترى في الانقلاب مدعاه لعقد استماع لمجلس
امنها المجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول غرب
افريقيا اكواس تفرض عقوبات على قاده
الانقلاب وعقوبات اقتصاديه تصل الى حد
تجميد اصول الني في البنوك المركزيه للدول
الاعضاء مع وقف التعاملات التجاريه كذلك
علق الاتحاد الافريقي عضويه النيجر فزعه
للديمقراطيه لم تشهد القاره الافريقيه
والمنطقه العربيه مثلها من قبل في السودان
يقع انقلاب للفريق عبد الفتاح البرهان
وصفه بانه محضو اجراء عادي دون ان تطالب
دوله بحمايه المسار الديمقراطي على علته
مصر ايضا مرت بتجربه مشابهه في المنطقه
العربيه ادار الغرب ظهره لاسواق الشعوب
العربيه للديمقراطيه والحكم المدني لتنتهي
ظاهره الربيع العربي الى فصل دموي في
تاريخ المنطقه يشير باصابع الاتهام الى
السدنه الديمقراطيه في العالم في النيجر
لن يحدثك احد عن المصالح المهدده لمن مسهم
التغيير في البلد
يكفي ان يكون الحديث عن الديمقراطيه فما
الحاجه الى الحديث عن المصالح